summer months are a time when
adolescents often experience periods of
no supervision since school is out and
many parents work
research shows June and July are the top
months for teenagers to begin
experimenting with drugs and alcohol um
no psychologist and CBS News contributor
Lisa d'amour is here with some tips on
constructive ways to keep our kids
occupied you always hear anecdotes about
parents just throwing a party September
1st or whatever starts up again what are
some constructive ways that kids can
occupy themselves well so one of the
things we know is that kids do well with
structure right and it's no teenagers
work hard during the school year they
deserve some downtime in the summer but
ideally a teenager should have some Ritz
are supposed to be something they're
supposed to do most days that we don't
want just huge swaths of unstructured
time for teenagers what happens if you
are a working parent and you are not
always around what do you how do you
structure that time in a way that works
well so one of the things we want to do
is try to fill it with meaningful
activities jobs on tier work sports
anything you know the kind of limits the
amount of unsupervised and unstructured
time they have one of the things when we
see when we look at the research is for
things to go wrong for teenagers
temptation and opportunity have to come
together right and lots of instruction
time and lots of lack of supervision
creates a lot of opportunity having you
said that having a paid job obviously
brings higher self-esteem which is
important but there studies now showing
that a few word a fewer kids are getting
jobs in the summer yeah why is that
happening
so the economy is shifting and so that
is making it harder for kids to get the
kinds of jobs they used to school years
or longer things like that and so though
this new research shows that paid jobs
actually boost self-esteem more than
volunteer work does perhaps because of
the pay or the sense that I need to be
there I've got to show up
we still want structure for kids so even
if they can't find a paid job they need
to do something meaningful with their
time the other thing is you know they
can fall back on the classics like
working in yards babysitting things like
that I get a piece last night of evening
news about how teenagers are foregoing
being lifeguards and so that's going to
older yes a workers because they're
taking those jobs instead one question
that a lot of parents have of teenagers
is how much independence
you give your child as far as who their
friends are what are they doing with
their friends you want them to be making
their own decisions but obviously you
needed to input that as well yes so a
lot of this comes down to the teenager
you know and one of the things that we
say all the time is the best predictor
of future behavior is past behavior you
know if you have a pretty well-behaved
teenager you can usually count on that
again limit the amount of time I think
that they have without any supervision
check in I'm always interested to in
terms of how teenagers assess risk you
know some teenagers assess it in terms
of what are the chances we're gonna get
caught you know other teenagers assess
it in terms of what are the chances
someone could get hurt right if you have
a kid in the first category you probably
want to keep a pretty close eye mm-hmm
this is this period of downtime the the
internet videogames beckon yes they do
how do you how do you and if you're not
at home how do you police that well
that's a good question I think you know
one of those things as you may have sort
of honor systems and then have some way
to check in on the honor system I think
the other thing is they need have other
places they're supposed to be right that
helps a lot the lemonade stand calls the
lemonade stand calls grandma's house
calls read a good book right the book
calls not to do more great to have you
gone thank you you bet and later this
morning Lisa will join us for a Facebook
live chat to continue the conversation
you can watch our our CBS this morning
Facebook page